in the midst of movie and TV show
reactions Le such a busy schedule around
here who's got time to prep gourmet
meals well that's where Factor steps in
Factor America's number one ready to eat
meal kit delivering fresh never frozen
meals right to your door take a look at
Factor's Gourmet plus lineup the three
bean vegan chili a symphony of toasted
spices and veggies and the coconut lime
curry tofu it's tropical and tantalizing
all the Gourmet feels ready in Just 2
minutes about diving into some roasted
veggie and pesto tortillini perfectly
roasted veggies with cheese tortillini
all draped in a creamy basil spinach
pesto salivating just pling that footage
back now while I'm a plant powered
individual I got the Mother-in-law
staying with us right now so with that
in mind for those who fancy Meats the
sun dried tomato chicken and black
pepper and sage pork chop are Rave
worthy the Factor's Gourmet plus even my
hectic days get a gourmet touch no more
grocery runs just pure deliciousness so
you're ready to elevate your food game
reject Nation jump in to factor75.com or
click below with real rex50 you're in
for a 50% off treat with your first box
dive into the Gourmet life people
all right guys we got ourselves Loki
season dose episode dose today John how
are you I'm an Ora boros of excitement G
coyi I am dosed up and ready yeah all
right use two
do ladies and gentlemen leave a like on
this video be sure to subscribe click
the notification Bell to get notified
when reaction for episode 3 is up here
on the channel cuz you know we're going
to be covering all of Loki season 2 also
we've been covering gen V go ahead check
that out as well we got two great comic
book shows airing on the same day that's
crazy and of course um I want to say a
massive thank you to all who have joined
our patreon via the shows and movies
that we've been covering lately and Loki
is one of those so full length through
AC and watch along where you syn with
your own copy of Loki available for our
super sexy rejects over at our patreon
page we also cover several shows over
there where there are reaction
highlights and watch along exclusively
included right now let's just get into
Loki I'm excited to continue this
journey that's who built this place
that's who's coming back she was going
to kill him Sy where is she I don't know
it looks like a 70 tor I haven't heard
that
yet thoughts no sy's not here just hop
to we got a hit on a 10 pad that
belonged to Hunter X5 before it went
dark like how they went to the 70s with
Doc and X5 not responding this our only
lead zaniac yeah Rafael Cassel is a wolf
is that supposed to be like uh Joe
Spinell and Maniac oh that's cool X5
isn't actor now or he's under cover
looks pretty real for
me M variants are original undercover
how do you feel about your meteoric rise
to F I don't know how I feel but I know
it look pretty darn good come on look at
this there be a zaniac 2 no sequel for
the
fans Mobius
W no I used to work with this guy he's a
friend from work you look great thank
you very much you look pretty good
yourself feel like we're in Zoolander
again that hansel's so hot right now
Hansel is he running now he is running
oh no no you're at the zaniac premiere
can I get your autograph anything for
whoa nice
v15 he's a superstar running down the
streets yeah how long has he been under
cover at least take your Ascot off
man come on Mobius you're going to ruin
my life here your life
here oh that's right Loki has powers
he's a God we so glad we're here God
those Ruffles
though let's get a Warner
Runner little Tom Cruz run for Tom
Heston again just nice to see actual
sets and long enough takes to tell
what's happening they went on location
to the
70s this says a mission impossible Vibe
it really
is come on
X5 did you really think you could outrun
me are you known for your
agility hi where's the rude boy off
to is the fancy going off the L whoa did
you L take
a oh he's going to get jumped by The Sex
Pistols back
up back up hey back up oh he did the
twirl oh you're the tough guy
[Music]
huh sophisticated X5 of course you doing
your own stunts
now you quit with the magic and fight
fair yes stop
[Music]
running nice the Shadows a this is great
right from the comics that's great
yeah shadow people feel like we barely
got to see Loki use his powers last
season little over the top don't you
think all the shadow
play I thought it was spot
on that's the real Loki y we haven't
seen Loki be mischievous in a bit I know
missed it it's like a superpowered agent
now you he's a full on t vaa agent now
you will tell us if you found Sylvie
right cuz I'm a criminal right okay come
on get in there what a fascinating time
Jump to go from the last episode to this
hunt him down now he's a criminal I feel
like we're missing some
stuff is he tiny oh just working Obie
could I get you to take a look at this
temp pad interesting do you think this
is a higher priority than preventing a
temporal
meltdown
everything you need to know about this I
wrote about it in
here I love him when are they going to
start selling those TVA handbooks 6
months later like the Ant-Man book oh I
need them R Slayer killed C20 attempted
to kill mobus threw me in time jail and
tried to take over the TVA why would
tracking her temp pad be a secret
recap right Shout It Out Eugene R Slayer
erased the data from her temp Pad but I
was able to piece together who sent the
last message and who was that should man
with the system is that with the red
light cuz we tried that already I'll try
it again cuz I don't think you had that
pressed back did you too
complicated chish here what to help you
focus if we don't work this out this
entire place is going to be destroyed
temporal meltdown this feels like a
office workplace kind of show as well
now yeah very quickly when I was in the
past Ren Slayer and he who remains it
sounded like they were Partners she
really
is full of
surprises that she just gets
progressively more vexed what is that
it's just a a rigged temp pad X5 says it
somehow blocks TVA tracking that's not
what it does oh my God yes you are more
essential MVP this definitely doesn't
block any trackers that's for sure how
are they going to fix that super easy
barely an inconvenience give it to
Casey let's take a run up Brad wolf now
it's going to be a cop show Brad knows
us and he knows our tactics but that's
what makes for an interesting chess
match okay most of all Brat's an
love how he's looking forward to
interrogating cool oh welcome back
reflection at the top too start treating
me like somebody who outranks you I
don't work here oh that's a good point
you should stop
talking it Blocks Your trackers no it
doesn't yeah no what is it designed
for X5 it's Brad weren't you the one
blabbering on and on about how we all
had lives I went down and got my life
what exactly are you mad at me about oh
my God this changes everything so broken
now you're just trying to make up for
all the terrible awful you've done
in your life you pathetic little man
character Arc setup keep going I wanted
to hit more good oh you're good Loki see
I've read your
file it's you file you're the problem
it's you're the problem it's you you
think you're special but you're not
doesn't matter what outfit you put on
play dress up or little lies you tell
come on Loki's black widowing him you
just make effort everything worse for
Mobius for B15 for your mother oh why
did you say that a trying to be a hero
man you're a villain
ooh do
[Laughter]
that thank you
Brad I have done some terrible awful
things and maybe that is who I AMS going
he knows is he bad cop now a
loser always happen always will be for
all time always and perhaps I've
been holding something back oh perhaps
I've just been waiting for a moment like
this look how puffy those lapels are so
let's try this one more
time where is Sylvie you're way too
obsessed with her he needs
therapy control your little pet Mobius I
got a little
tense hey you want to hear a good one
knock knock who Z Mobius Brad Brad who
that's show
this and I don't want that to happen to
you we get you back down there so they
don't forget about you how's that sound
you would do that amazing you seeing
this Mobius you could be an actor
I'm not an actor I'm an analyst but
thank you you could be a jety commercial
So Meta I mean who even are you on the
timeline do you know I think it does
matter because none of this is real well
okay I can't wait to find that out
Mobius isn't even your real name well
it's what I answer to do you have any
idea what her Expressions this whole
scene you know they took our lives and
you're still here I mean it's kind of
weird man I mean you need to wake up
Brad is controlling this you need to
wake aw is you're nothing she's nothing
I don't even know where to start with
that but you're oh until you wake up
you're just a nowhere man you're
a silly little man silly little did he
just Will Smith him I think he did yeah
keep my existences name out your oh my
God Mobius is a Will Smith variant then
keep my noname out of your mouth he
didn't get under my skin he got under
your skin are you all right I've never
seen you like this before see me like
what it's okay I'm not judging the
longest chain of file cabinets where are
we I was following you no I was
following you how was that possible he
was in front you were clearly ahead of
me how about slice of pie hell yeah
nothing pie can't fix key lime key lime
pie back to first season a throwback has
a reference ref steg are rewarding me
for knowing a thing I paid attention
it's really
good it
is I'm so impressionable now I want pie
it's the only pie they have here listen
that wasn't
tactical I lost it what you remember
that time I was so angry with my father
and my brother I went down to earth and
I held the whole of New York City
hostage not just that you murdered a
bunch of people tried to use the
mindstone on Tony star it didn't work so
I threw him off the building let me tell
you something wasn't
[Music]
tactical sometimes our emotions get the
better of us you are the therapist Loki
you never wanted to visit your place on
the
timeline or did you don't you want to
see the life you're supposed to live
before they kidnapped you and brought
you into the TVA not really come on you
know you do it's not my life but it
could have been it isn't this is this is
a great reversal of the dynamic of
season 1 I'm even sitting across the
he's like relaxed I get it you might
think twice and case something bad or
something good something bad I can
handle what if it's something
good oh so
despondent what if he goes to Earth and
finds he lives in a jet ski Factory oh
they
sporks good observation the most
futuristic utensil Easter egg sport he
found her maybe didn't turn her in he
wants to continue to live his best life
on the timeline he wants more time to be
Brad wolf Brad wolf is pretty sick just
got to make him talk
well come on you're the god of
Mischief right I love how this is like
the time is a flat circle production
design throughout it even this pie room
and the circles above them in a big
circle even though it was like two
different shots it's like looks the
exact
[Music]
same
what oh
no oh jeez what does that even mean whoa
the
vampire
oh time to get
mischievous hi please the door open so
confident going to try the hard ball
tactics this time uh something like that
okay punch him in the
nuts what is
this oh yeah interesting to put it in
his POV yeah that was cool you have
information inform you don't want to
give it to us so how do we find common
ground you going to suck all the arrows
room which one of you came up with this
little script May's controller can't
start the festivities without that
little baby stand by it's all part of
the bit what exactly is this thing
supposed to be I don't know but I'm very
curious hey open up good act guys
perfect there is actually one other
option no no hey commit more to it
Mobius come on sell it that thing does
not work without the controller though
this
one okay great we're going to have a
little yeah get worried did you find
Sylvie simple question really doesn't
mean we can't enjoy ourselves as we go
along I hope Loki does something truly
bad I'm not trying to be a hero bride
I'm a
villain remember no Loki M you got to
sell this better hey L you're not a
villain now he's actually worried
earlier I said some really hurtful
thing you don't know what you're doing
with that what does this one
do
whoa oh yes samam sorry uh could hurt
yourself there I guess there's a
learning curve with this thing right
yeah there is a learning curve you know
you could kill me with that could I do
appreciate good Rhythm and seam workor
there you
go let me try this let me try this
W all right sorry that's only made it
smaller I've done some terrible awful
things yeah you have you're doing one
right
now
well
okaying at it I swear I don't know where
they are ride what a cruel way to crush
someone I want to believe you but you're
just you're such a good actor I lied I
was supposed to go look for syv I bailed
I didn't buy
it
w wa dude I went down there I went to
get my life none of this is real well if
none of this is real I guess you aren't
either whoa
dude who wa I'll tell you where she is
she has a new
life the plan worked so they found
Sylvia and they just let her live yeah
but I found her first she's on a
branch little bit of Mischief I as good
as your plan thank you I bought it you
did that last bit not the beginning I
thought it the end I did he's a good
analyst actor anal actor X-Men it's got
to be hey OB this is Casey I I thought I
could help die KC o it's meant to be
going to
die ni nice to meet you we're all going
to die did you try the C12 bypass
pathway that won't work are you sure of
course I wrote
it Dad you wrote the TVA guide book
you've read it practically memorized
it will you sign mine you signed my
guide yeah just next to your picture
hold on containment do are locked only
the person who designed it can open it
with a Life Scan of his temporal Aura
yeah yeah and he's dead so without Miss
Min to help us override the lock
we're stuck where is she we have to
convince a rogue artificial intelligence
to come back to work we got to do it
fast see what happens
Disney I'll built the device but you
need to find a way in or it won't matter
a miss m is busy designing the secret
Invasion
credits you go ahead I'm going to head
on back all right wait wait wait wait
why are you so jumpy it's making me
nervous I'm not jump I'm not nervous
yeah you're like you you want to take
off
little bits of psychology are great
stressed m is this all the
time I have to find out what she know
just twitching in the background I'll do
the talking be
ready he so agitated can you refill the
straw when you get a SI I've already
done it I don't know Sylvia I know you
want a normal sea this seems like the
most boring thing this is that's what
you want to think textbook normal try
all of it
look how my gold stars she
has this feels
tense I'm not going anywhere to try get
some apple pie he's going to be like 30
lbs heavier by the end of this season so
much
pie like the rendition on their music
listen I haven't got all day are you
going to order something or what can we
talk my break's in 5 minutes perfect how
lucky perfect man knows how to travel
through time talk fast
got to fill that drink up you work here
why are you so resistant towards
him she got a green truck she still
loves him Sylvie I was in the future and
I saw you the TVA is in danger and you
were there I need to know why but this
factor is into why look as much as I'd
love to see the TVA burnt to the ground
I have no intention of going back there
my life's here now we got a whole new
haircut it's going to happen is it that
sounds a lot like the future's already
been written we both know that it hasn't
not anymore I made sure of that free
will baby Sy if you and I don't work
together on this I can't
guarante here with your TVA
this is tense this is bigger
than the TVA this is about everything
all time always the TVA is the only
defense what I saw of you is true then
there's nothing that stands between this
world and utter destruction so was it
that Sylvie who pruned him I still think
he pruned himself you were setting us up
for an ambush hell you were just set
setting us up for a great
meal what is happening right now they're
just it's like they're going over every
detail of their relationship that has
ever happened why complicated bot to
unpack when you're basically in a
relationship with yourself you say
opposites
attract
no this is such a great flourish can we
just talk for a second about how crazy
life is I mean 10 minutes ago you were
screaming at me you're nothing and now
here we are enjoying a meal like
gentlemen you slap me in the face I'm
not going to C you a shake
okay just enjoy this tell me about
zaniacs you don't care about my movie
Brad I saw the poster it looked
scary it's not scary it's elevated
Thriller yes yes Cinema thank you very
much it's an 824 movie you got to get
your own tickets I'm not hooking you up
for this I will this feels improvised I
love them so much why don't we just get
this to go how about that it it packs
right up and we get out of here get me
back to the sacred timeline it's like
although now it's just get me out of
here which
is is this a setup oh what's going on
yep
nothing oh man oh no you just going to
give everyone Free Will and walk away
that's the way it works I am God sorry
to interrupt I think Brad's got
something that he might want to get off
his chest zaniac is getting a sequel and
you're both
invited we stay here we're all going to
die they're going to die orange shirt
she's going to die we are all going to
die
this
unless
whoa they're going to bomb every Branch
yeah including this one okay that theory
is true I'll show you the 15 incom hey
right back into the uniform now she's
got a reason to go to the TVA we need to
know where this attack is coming from
call is coming from inside the house
she's going to kill them all start
tracking those charges that's a cool way
to do that reveal oh my God like a video
game yeah portal they've proven 30% of
the branches Mobius they're killing
billions take dots down now this feels
like a video game Mission that's how
they're bombing all the timelines at
once they're all connected to that
central control panel that's our Target
it really does
okay
d
set up what you can shut up docs she
wants time
Freedom damn there's too many I'm going
to call
OB OB is overworked as it is you're
going to get a stomach cramp from the
McDonald's oh
boy don't overthink
it oh yeah they could it's Grace to
bring that back make magic together how
much damage is already done though is
this all of Doc's loyalist everyone who
didn't an escape Mobius you should come
back OCC that quickly episode 2 mission
accomplished oh
nice oh oh all right we're at the end of
episode button I'm afraid of what's
about to happen take me back to
McDonald's w
it's literally like looking at a
Lifeline those are people those are
lives
oh oh they're probably going to get
Victor timley to get some
help that'd be interesting
[Music]
yeah she with Victor timely is this the
best you not can do
there was nothing we could
do some defense wof TVA is the problem
it's broken it's rotten don't it's
harded you can't fix the institution
from
[Music]
within this is a remarkable
advertisement for McDonald's really is
working next time we're at the TVA the
sacred timeline will just be golden
arches true timeline do you think you'll
be in tomorrow though yeah cool cool no
is your mom on her way to pick you up uh
she'll be here I'm good oh he
crushing make a choice you have free
will to choose oh are you a hero or a
villain let's talk about it guys let's
talk about it all righty guys well
you're listening to us on Apple or
Spotify we uh just watched Loki season 2
episode 2 we're going to talk about
right now please rate the video uh but
before we do that oh ladies and
gentlemen um thank you again to everyone
who has been buying some reject apparel
at www. reation shop.com um I'm finally
wearing this one this is RR this like
the
ratings great really comfortable I got a
different color feel like Iain get the
black ones we are full of language uh
bad jokes and nipple chills and then we
also got uh we're selling these as well
these Marvel inspired t-shirts as well
not Marvel Inspire they're just straight
up Marvel right here it's like a lowy
tarot card and John's all decked out but
of course we got other ones like our
recently launched Ahsoka snip snip shirt
if you know you know and then we got our
child protection services sure as I like
to call it and you know we just got a
whole bunch more and we are creatively
involved in them ourselves so thank you
guys one of the absolute best ways to
support the channel is by rocking some
RR merch showing you are a true citizen
of the reject Nation but yeah guys let's
kick it off all right let's do this uh
let's go Coy what would you rate it out
of 10 out of 10 this episode seven yeah
okay John like uh
7.8 all right I'm going to go 7.5 whoa
I'm the one sitting in why you asked me
first see the shill negative all right
John's the highest John's the highest
one here that's right all right go John
I won't drink my CH
go uh no I mean like this episode
definitely had uh a slightly more um
what am I trying to say say like the the
plot beats of this episode do maybe feel
a bit like oh crap we're already dealing
with certain things but um I've just
been so enthralled by the atmosphere
they've been going for the tone the the
percolating dread but just the general
sense of like something is off something
is wrong I we can't tell what it is but
it's something close by it's something
in the room I think they're good at
drawing that air of mystery and that air
of paranoia and uh and and immediacy for
this and so uh yeah like the whole fun
like I thought it was a really fun game
with Brad that ultimately led into and
paid off with everything with Sylvia and
now it seems like we're certainly kind
of getting off to it's like I feel like
the first episode established like the
tonal and the broader Stakes of the
season and now this episode seemed like
it's kind of honing in on like some of
the more immediate Stakes um and so yeah
like you know there are certain plot
beats I think could have been maybe a
little a bit a little bit more smooth um
but you know as just an unfolding
chapter of this journey I'm couldn't be
more enthralled and I love the prospect
of Casey and Ora Boris you know like
working together and all those things uh
yeah there's there's so much to this
episode that I loved so anything that
was maybe a little bit like that I might
have been a little taken a back by
timing wise you know was all pretty much
compensated for in other ways and in
some moments of true tension and true
thrill and all that stuff so that's a
fair point Fair Point Asian persuasion
that's right OB and Casey right uh
Kon I thought yeah that referring to me
as the Asian persuasion I was very
confused then was Kon now we're back to
confusion I uh I dropped it down a
little because I the first episode's
like a I didn't know we were using
decimals but first episode if decimal
would be like a 98 like first episode
was damn near perfect for me uh I did
find this episode it had to do some time
jumps in order to make the mystery work
and I did find that undermind the stakes
for my experience personally uh like I
would have preferred to have a little
bit more coherence between leaving and
then Brad jumping in and I understood
that that is how the mystery unraveled
and how they made it all work but it did
feel like by the time we got to the
stakes there was only 5 minutes the
episode left and the weight of the prune
felt like wait out of nowhere that's
what they're doing like the timeline of
the episode didn't seem to line up with
the timeline of the things happening
like there was the mystery of Sylvie
there was his nervousness and then it
was like we have to make sure it has
Stakes all of a sudden it's like they're
pruning immediately and the causality of
their mission didn't seem to line up
with the actual events occurring like I
I think that that would have occurred
whether the mystery happened or not it
it was like that was happening in
another room so it would have still been
unless they solved it a little faster it
just it the jux position of the the a
plot and B plot felt like it left some
to be desired in a big enough way to
drop it a two uh point system for me I
loved the scenes uh of like just two
people talking like I always do with the
show I really enjoyed the pi scene
really enjoyed seeing Rafael casselle
get to like act uh his eyeballs out
opposite Tom Heston that scene um of
them playing like chess mentally was a
blast I did go from Owen Wilson is
pretending to him actually being afraid
Loki was going to get away with
something uh I thought the Mischief had
had actually gotten to the point where
Loki might have done something evil and
like Mobius have been like only go this
far and then he went further that that
was what I meant by like him pushing him
so I it's just something felt not quite
as tight as the First episodes like
Precision this did feel like it was a
10-minute longer edit that was missing
some things that built the tension more
naturally enough that it dropped down
some for me yeah um I I agree with
everyone's points I
do agree with with everything you guys
are saying uh this I love the acting in
it um that was like probably my favorite
aspect of it the acting in particular
was great what's that actor's name that
you love Rafael Cassell Raphael dude
blind spotting if you've never seen
blind spotting that's where he's yeah
dude damn I could not place it he's guy
off the they're like they go way back
into the bay together they they've been
making music and movies together forever
not place it dude I love that guy well
that makes a lot more sense now because
one thing I was I I think I said it out
loud was I was there should be more
rapping yeah it was like there's the
Rhymes uh it was the the the rhythm of
the dialog yeah no like the there's
there is such great scene work with the
Rhythm and the back and forth and I like
how a lot of this just feels like actual
scene workor with a true true life to it
you know what going back to like secret
Invasion that was one of the compliments
we would give it but here there's actual
like it's more like jazz and this time
around you know I feel like Kevin feige
watched a bunch of movies he liked he
was like all right we got everything
every all at once is OB we got a blind
spotting like I feel like he watched St
like let's bring them into Marvel yeah
yeah I mean and the cinematography again
does still stay consistent in terms of
really shining there's a lot of awesome
symmetry throughout uh but I I was taken
aback by is I thought when we first saw
we first saw him as the actro I was like
oh this must be his life before he was
turned you know a very think that was an
intentional mislead yeah I thought
that's what it was going to be and then
oh he just was has been here and then to
go from the first episode where it was
really if you kind of the only example
I'm going to do this is not really a
comparison it's really just to to
present an example if you look at the
first season you know one thing to get
us um focused was we need to find out
who is this Hunter who this mysterious
Hunter who's killing other variants
right that was like the the main mission
at hand as we grow out the rest of the
Mysteries in the world and then the last
episode was really focused on chaos is
happening King is coming he who remains
other variants of him are coming and I
actually feel like this episode started
kind of losing sight of that focus and
started becoming about like what are
these other TVA members doing and it it
weird is they're they're they're
providing these like melancholic moments
and and these like harrowing bits
especially towards the end that
conceptually yeah do sound like really
Bleak and dire uh but it doesn't really
hit when it at the end of the day I am
just look as an audience I'm just
there's a lot I'm keeping up with and
there's a lot that I'm paying attention
to and I'm just looking at a line of you
know per
like that's what I mean the acting is
really good yeah like from B15 everyone
is great in that moment um but I I'm
like sure it is it is that kind of like
jaded thing that a lot of us feel like
with with real life news you know yeah
when you get inundated with stimuli and
you're like okay 72 people died you
don't feel the weight of the 72 people
much l billions yeah yeah I mean as as
messed up as it is to say something like
that it's just the truth of the matter
and so to me there were just things
about the pacing that were just feeling
a little bit questionable to me towards
especially towards the end because like
they really took their time with
interrogating Brad so they really took
their time there I feel like they saw
the gold they had and then the episode
had to be a certain link so they cut
other like it just felt like pay strong
and it's like they introduced like the
TVA is what they're really doing Doc is
doing this and okay I guess they they
took care they took out them really fast
these are the end of her loyalists I'm
like but there's no real waight to hear
we just kind of feel like we just kind
of rushed through this and now we're
supposed to feel this like gravit this
gravity of the all these deaths of that
just happened there was no real build
yeah there was no real buildup into it
this episode had two this felt like two
episodes worth of major plot lines leil
into one because you could have done all
the Brad like the Brad stuff started to
feel to me kind of like it could have
flirted with being akin to that She-Hulk
episode where she goes and sees Donnie
Blaze
could have this it but then get that
battle at the end and that is a huge
piece of stakes and I think yeah seeing
the Lions shrivel up would have hit a
lot harder in an episode about that yeah
if it was if it was a race against to
prevent that if the episode was focused
on that CU we didn't even know that was
our race yeah we didn't even know until
5 minutes before the ticking clock just
ended like we got to the 11th Hour of a
ticket I thought it was going to end on
the Cliffhanger of
that episod was like okay I guess this
just happened and I'm like okay now we
got a whole new bag of worms we got to
deal with um but so much work that I
can't drop it below a seven but that's
hu no yeah I I would still recom I I
still liked it uh because there's
there's so many great acting moments in
here and while the emotional beasts
maybe don't hit as strong and I I mean I
was never quite believing it was like
yeah we know Brad's eventually going to
give up the information so I like that
they're taking their time and against
really good scam workor um and and I
like what they're setting up especially
with Mobius of him discovering his past
and and the asking the existential
questions and the Flippo too like you
know some of the most talked about
moments of season 1 was them just
sitting across from each other having
conversations about the philosophies of
life and existence and purpose and what
and and then you know that I I like the
lived in conversation that Mobius is
presenting about you know if I'm bad my
life before I'm bad I could live with
that but if I'm good like oh I'd be
missing there's like that fear missing
out I thought that was really strong and
more comp telling you know as opposed to
the opposite of but if I'm bad do I want
to know that like oh know that it would
mess with you you was like but I have a
purpose here as mobus if that was the ab
plot I would have been really happy with
this episode and then I like the idea of
ending on a cliffhanger and then
starting the episode with the
ramification so you have the weight to
it it's literally like make this episode
40 minutes without the last 10 and then
open like I just the pacing really
changed the stakes for me this this was
interesting cuz cuz I thought like the
character and the like the the tonal the
spiritual writing was really good but
yeah like the the nuts and bolts plot
writing wasn't as good and uh I I have
some questions about Sylvie uh
because super there's no uh I feel like
there should be some level of
accountability that she's not taken at
all like whatsoever I think that's her
being and Loki doesn't even seem at all
perturbed by like hey like that would
have been the first like there's a lot
happening because you chose you chose to
do this you Ked me out you know I think
she's keeping him at and he's just like
still soft yeah I think that damn will
break I hope so I don't really feel an
intense I don't really feel like there's
anything building within Loki about that
what she did but I do feel like I I felt
a lot of that initial sort of like shy I
mean like there's all of that history
there but also like I don't want to mess
this situation up because there's
probably a hope of rekindling some of
that from before so you don't want to
just charge in Gung oh like you know
your accountability for this chaos
that's raining right now yeah he's
trying to fix the relationship before
he's like we talk about that thing if
they don't unpack that though I would be
upset yes if it doesn't happen in the
next coming episodes but like just
getting her back just having them meet
like I I kind of expected it to be like
yeah there will be other stuff at hand
this episode and they'll have tension
but that'll get resolved later but I can
understand you wanting it just because
it is such a huge deal and it is like it
is affecting all of of time and space
essentially so part of me is like yeah
it's fair to expect somebody to just
jump out and be like you realize what's
happening right now I do hope the next
episode is about their relationship
enough to flesh out those issues and to
ground things a bit more and and then I
guess the last thing to think about um I
mean I don't really want to spend too
much time on it
is when you are seeing the craziness
that's happening across the Multiverse I
can't help but go has has this been
affecting stuff that was happening in
phase four you know I still think that
there's multiple timelines we've met
yeah I still I mean one of those prune
timelines might be like when the only
place the celestials
exist where that guy is sticking out of
the SE I love that movie but nobody else
did so let's prune the eternals don't
worry don't worry it's on its own
timeline the whole universe maybe not
anymore they just got qu I got question
it's like you got to at the end of the
day because it's connected conceptually
that's all the sacred timeline which is
what's safe conceptually sure but I do
think there's going to be a discovery of
there being multiple timelines that we
have already met yeah and I think
Deadpool's going to deal with that all
right well still overall plenty to
really like um but and and I think the
the parts of it that don't hit it as
strong only really cast a a shadow
because the first episode was so strong
that when something's not quite
clicking you're like
okay is not bad I just noticed yeah yeah
still if it was Rotten Tomatoes you
would still be like that's still fresh
still fresh still fresh you say seven
out of 10 you're like whoa low but if
you're like 70% right like freshman s
out of 10 is deceptive cuz seven out of
10 is like that's pretty good but if you
go like by school rating like that's a c
Andy that's average we have a public
education system problem in this country
it's an average score yes all right guys
we'll leave your thoughts Down Below on
what you thought of Loki season 2
episode 2 uh thank you so much for being
here but before we exit out let's do a p
all right John we got to play catchup
here since we're behind on shout outs
and there's only so many days left in
the mon we got to shout out two patrons
of course I have an idea I want to see
how strong chat gbt would be at
replacing a generated script here
excellent so I'm going to need you to
pick two people here all right all right
here we go let's do uh let's do David
Gandy okay and let's do adilia
Chamberlain David Gandy and Adelia
Chamberlain all right but we're gonna
need to give chatti UT some information
about what we know they've been patrons
for a very long time so we we've gotten
to know them quite a bit sure all right
so how would you describe okay hold on a
second um I need to I need you to create
a
scene um of two characters interacting
just want the
dialogue just want the dialogue stomia
if you will a what stick athia is a
script where it's just dialogue you knew
I would not know what that is stick ayia
you don't have to tell you don't it's
fine SP how you spell that how to
spell it jeez only say words you know
how to spell okay God a simia if you
will and you will here's their
personalities all right let's go with
David Gandy how would you describe David
Gandy David Gandy is uh soft spoken calm
and collected calm collected uh uh he's
uh selfless selfless very caring plays
guitar does martial arts does martial
arts photographer photographer MH and
lives in Arizona got hella action
figures got a bunch of action figures
loves old movies yeah Cinema copile
copile what do you think David Gandy
would be dressed up as on Halloween oh
David Gandy would be dressed up as
Indiana
Jones dressed up as Indiana
Jones for
Halloween now Adelia Chamberlain how
would you describe personality Adelia
Chamberlain is um uh fiercely loyal
fiercely loyal she's uh resourceful and
intelligent
resourceful
intelligent creative creative just likes
to write loves to read books yes
liberal yeah has a good moral compass
strong moral compass
yeah shy shy yeah um uh but also uh
geeky definitely attentive but also like
really into a lot of different uh pop
culture things copile as well loves Dune
also copile what would she be for
Halloween oh um uh uh what's her name
elasa girl elast she dressed as elasa
girl from from yeah The Incredibles from
The Incredibles for Halloween
alrighty here's their
personalities and have them meeting each
other or catching up while bumping into
one
another during trick or treaty o yeah I
love it let's see love this theme all
right setting a dimly lit Suburban
Street lined with Old Oaks and leaf
covered sidewalks children laugh and
scream in the distance the soft glow
from lanterns and Jacko lanterns gives a
hallowed Ambience to the chilly
Halloween evening all right I'm going to
play David all right I will be adilia
all right remember David is dressed as
Indiana Jones
sure oh I'm sorry I didn't see you
there it's all right I was just lost in
the world of oracus in my mind you're
Indiana Jones right that I am and you
elasa girl from The Incredibles I
appreciate appreciate the attention to
detail thank you it's one of my favorite
movies Pixar's Masterpiece if you ask me
though you seem to have a classic taste
Harrison Ford in his pride I do love the
classics this compelling dialogue
there's a certain charm in old movies
you ever sit down with an old film reel
and just lose yourself in the monochrome
world I love when characters talk about
themselves as characters uh absolutely
they have a Timeless Beauty although I'm
more of a bookworm there's something
about that's utterly captivating I can
weirdly this is how they would talk to
each other I can understand that I'd
like to Capture Moments with my camera
Arizona Landscapes mostly but anything
that tells the story accurate uh Arizona
that's far from here what brought you to
this neighborhood tonight visiting
family and I couldn't resist the Allure
of trick-or-treating in classic Suburbia
the Landscapes are one thing but the
memories they're something else I write
to capture those memories to build
worlds and craft
Tales but speaking of stories you must
have some Tales from your Martial Arts
Journey that I am very aware
of yeah it's all about balance much like
the strings of my guitar true oh yes
thank you yeah do you play any
instruments no but I can craft a
narrative around
I've always admired people with a
musical Touch by the way I couldn't help
but notice the action figures peing from
your back wow it's just like when
Marvel's like insert this yep let's give
me that last line again John yeah I just
couldn't help notice the action figures
peeking from your bag as guilty as
charged they're all all for me I promise
some are for my younger cousins although
I might be keeping that vintage Han Solo
like bued it's all right we all have our
inner geek speaking of which have you
read Dune only once but I've watched the
old movie adaptation a masterpiece in
its own right ah another point of
connection I believe this Halloween
might just be the start of a beautiful
copile friendship with a Sprinkle of
geekiness on top too many more
conversations under the soft glow of
movie projectors oh both characters
continue their Journey Down the Lane
there Silhouettes slowly merging into
the evening Haze bonded by their shared
passions oh my God we have everything to
worry about AI replacing this is all
this is ready to go green light this now
this is Aaron Soren material at its Fest
yeah man this is going to be in theaters
next week ah well and now I know what it
would be like if David and Adelia ever
met in person yeah
[Music]
definitely